we couldn't trust the politicians on  this that we needed to do it because  they weren't doing it so we're here  together and we keep waiting for them to  do something about it you can't rely on  the adults that this has to be a student  movie so I guess we'll come together  because we have to for the entire nation  we are the revolution and we can do this  together students are the heart and soul  of this movement and I've told them that  because I've met with a lot of them  young people have literally been the  forefront of every movement if you look  at the anti-war movement if you look at  the civil rights movement these were  pioneered by young people because young  people are the people that are looking  forward  [Music]